there he is right-hander jayco derisi
getting things started for the houston
astros on this saturday day game on the
season 74 innings pitch he has allowed
67
hits era at 474.
see against seattle at 6-5-2 e-r-a
and in the last two starts against the
seattle mariners that's what you see is
at 6-5-2 era so ready to go with jp
crawford leading up
foul tip caught by maldonado this game
starts with a strikeout as crawford goes
down for the first out might have been a
split that didn't split you can see the
tumbling action on our mattress from
super mode but it stays up crawford
tried to get after it couldn't get on
top of it now order rizzy will face
mitch haniger
on the ground jacob wilson is there
makes the play across to yuli and
there's two outs here's abraham toro
no score in the top of the first seeger
at second and france at first for the
mariners
goes the other way for a base hit around
third comes seeger here comes the throw
by taylor jones it will be
in timeout at home play
taylor jones throws a strike from left
field against seeger trying to score how
about taylor jones was in the original
lineup at first base now out in left
field has a chance to gun down a runner
and guess what
got him
for logan gilbert a bit of an advantage
is the first time he's going to face
houston they haven't seen him before 16
starts on the air a 5-4 record a 4-4-2
e-r-a and a 77 in the third he has 87
strikeouts a nice number for him there
87 over 77 in third correa coming in
with a five-game hitting streak got a
pretty good runner at third base and
jose altuve
there's a ball on the ground that'll get
the job done altuve scores as carlos
correa grounds out to short rbi number
66 on the air for correa it's a
one-nothing game he heads to the second
inning
ahead 0-2
ground ball left side there is wilson
lone defender on that side his throw is
low they're going to stay he's still out
at first base barely was hustling down
the line fraley is out that's not an
easy pick right there but he
consistently holds his ground order izzy
peering over the glove delivers
swing and a miss torrens goes down on a
1-2 pitch odor rizzy has his second
strikeout odor is he the leg kick and
the pitch swing and a miss kellnick goes
down on a fast ball off the plate that
is three strikeouts for odorizzi a one
two three second in a strong inning as
the astros lead one nothing bottom of
the third jacob wilson will lead things
off jacob the third baseman today for
the astros but it's two and one and
jacob wilson getting the start as he
drives one deep to left field back goes
freely near the wall
it's off the wall
wilson in the second base he's heading
for three jacob wilson will be
safe for third his first major league
extra base hits a triple jacob wilson
needed something good to happen and he
made it happen getting that surprise
start as the astros had to shuffle that
lineup with chaz mccormick coming out of
the lineup and you get jacob wilson
going into launch mode
getting it into the nooks and crannies
of that left center field portion of
minima park as jacob wilson introduces
himself to the fans here at mid-may park
he had to put his head down and
eventually get to third base
nicely done with maldonado at the plate
ball gets away and here comes wilson he
will score first pitch to maldonado
bounces away
and the astros get another run on the
wild pitch it's two nothing hold on
trying to add to a two nothing lead here
with two on and two outs gilbert set
here's the pitch
jordan hits a high fly ball to left
fraley is back he is near the crawford
boxes looking up good
three-run jack
jordan alvarez
that ball kept carrying it found its way
into the first couple of rows of the
crawford boxes it is five-nothing astros
and he likes to hit tanks
that go 400-plus feet
but if you can figure out how to have
mistakes like this creep into the
crawford boxes who knows what this guy
could end up doing here at minutemaid
park there's taylor jones leading off
the bottom of the fourth inning for the
astros who lead the mariners five
nothing
taylor jones drives one deep to left
field forget about it almost up on the
train tracks in the astros lead
six to nothing brandly looking for his
first hit he has grounded out and fly
down the o2 to brantley there's a ground
ball right side that one gets through
altuve will score michael brantley and
rbi single at seven nothing astros we
have a new pitcher for the seattle
mariners just recalled today the
right-hander
robert duggar taylor jones the first
batter to face duggar in his return to
the big leagues
ground ball fair ball down the third
base line that's going to bounce off the
wall and score brantley yuley the third
taylor jones with an rbi double
astros lead this game eight to nothing
have a day taylor four hits in the
inning for the astros they scored two
more runs and lead this game eight to
nothing
that ball lined into right field falling
quickly that's down for a hit one run
scores taylor jones trying to score he
is
safe at home play two rbi base hit
by jake myers the astros in double
figures for the second straight game it
is ten nothing now ten to nothing too
old
there's a line drive jacob wilson
has a multi-hit game
myers will be waved around he'll score
on this double by wilson with a head
first slide it's 11 to nothing jacob
wilson his first multi-hit game of his
career
three for three today with three runs
scored
one shot that's gonna be down four hit
game for altuve rbi single as wilson
crosses the plate
it's an even dozen for the second
straight game 12-nothing astros
don't put some pressure on him
grounded out the third and struck out
hannigan gets into one deep left
down the line and that is a home run for
mitch hadiger home run number 28. astros
looking for their third consecutive win
pitch on the way
taylor jones drives one deep to center
field and that's off the wall two more
rbis for taylor jones alvarez and guriel
score jones is going to have himself a
triple it is 14-1 astros three-quarters
of the way to a cycle there's jake myers
that's a fly ball that'll be deep enough
to score a run and it's
drifting deep to right caught on the
wall
mitch hanigar makes a nice play that's a
sac fly adding another run to the total
astros leading 15-1 in the ninth inning
the mariners are down to their final out
swing and a missed ball game over astros
dominate on a saturday afternoon in
downtown houston 15-1.